estamos muy cerca a menos de 20
kilómetros de la ciudad de donest la
capital no solamente de la provincia que
tiene su nombre sino de toda la región
del Don Vázquez desde hace ocho años que
yo en control de los separatistas y está
hoy en día como el centro neurálgico de
las fuerzas rusas en esta batalla por el
don vast durante años aquí muy en la
cercanía donde nos encontramos una línea
de posiciones de defensa de un lado de
otro que se mantuvo sin moverse sin
embargo en los últimos meses y
especialmente semanas estas líneas han
empezado a ceder en algunas posiciones
debido a la gran presión de las fuerzas
rusas y lo que nos cuentan algunos
comandantes y algunas posiciones es que
lo que a ellos han hecho es han
preferido retroceder para salvar hombres
dejando a estas tropas algunas veces en
poblaciones que están totalmente
destruidas y en circunstancias muy
difíciles
que queden allí para más tarde si tienen
la oportunidad Y esperan que si poder
avanzar y recuperar nuevamente estas
posiciones lo que sí nos dicen es que
como hemos visto ya en la población de
bac mudo en Soledad que actualmente está
en control de la fuerza rusa eso también
en otras poblaciones más hacia el este
de la región del Don vast esta guerra se
intensifica en este sector del país el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin ha
hablado de que quiere tener el control
de esta región lo más rápido posible y
es tal vez la única posibilidad que
tienen sus fuerzas de tener alguna
Victoria así sea pírrica en este país
después de los fracasos que tuvieron
tanto en el norte como en la región de
kiev como la región del jarquífona
capital gersón que fue retomada por las
fuerzas ucranianas hace semanas así que
en la medida que se acerca el
aniversario de la invasión se recrudece
esta batalla en el don Vasco visto
durante estos días y además vuelven y
confirman que han traído una gran
cantidad de hombres no solamente
paramilitares de las fuerzas Wagner Sino
de todos los sectores del ejército y de
las fuerzas rusas que hacen que tengan
muchísimo más presión en este lugar